[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody
what is that Persia here with the homie
clockwork and we are back with some more
battle for the grid action because
they've just been pumping out this sweet
juicy content left and right every
single day on the grind and now lurid
said has been released
brand-new patch update live in in
effects probably the best version of the
game to date so you guys gonna wanna
check it out because not only is that
patch free but it's from what clock said
the closest iteration to what this game
should be and that is actually a pretty
bold statement from a developer in my
opinion so I'm excited it's here about
all the changes
what's up clock what's going on thanks
so much for having us of course yeah and
again you know we've been waiting so
long fat version 1.4 out it's just it
was already awesome we put 1.4 man so
you know before you begin just want to
let everyone out there know and everyone
that's watching that version 1.4 is out
right now and it's a free update so with
that update you get story mode act 3
you also get an extended training mode
our excuse me extended tutorial and you
get a host of combat adjustments and
improvements which I'll go over in a bit
and you also get Lord Zedd available and
DLC along with the other three season
pass characters at time for excluding
people are pink and Daisy oh you and I
all part of the season one
[Music]
we are in there yes out it's out for all
for all consoles Nintendo switch ps4
Xbox one and of course Nintendo switch
and Xbox do have cross play enabled as
long as you have an end way playa count
which is also free yeah so please check
it out if you haven't yet definitely
alright I gotta know I need these patch
notes I want the deets fer for the
details I have notes here because
there's so many changes so if you want
to see the complete list of patch notes
you go to battle for the grid comm go to
I think like the new section and you'll
see like the updates there but yeah I'll
get straight into it so oh so we know
what we'll do is we'll talk over passion
notes and if you guys want to play with
us online we'll get in some online
matches later we'll let you know how
shortly so version 1.4 again like oh
wait 1.4 I was about to link 1.3 1.4 so
this is the 1.4 launch again new
characters new new content and new
combat changes so let's get right into
it so the I would say I want to talk
about you know there's kind of changes
not only Universal changes but across
all the characters but I want to go over
some of the major Universal changes that
the first one is that we have added
ground bounces into the game whoo this
combo right here with gold Ranger
normally that would have spiked to the
ground but now there's a ground bounce
right so
combos like right and I think what's
good about the ground bounce is that it
really does two things one it just opens
up every single character is combo
routes right you can put the groundouts
at the beginning right and common from
there you can put it at the end but
another thing that it does and this is
kind of a feature that is interesting
about I see this a lot newer fighting
games where and you saw this in Marvel 3
actually where the ground bounce it kind
of serves as a way to correct your combo
right so let's say I get a weird
confirmation like this right and I don't
really know what to do with it I can
always go into a ground bounce and then
that will correct like my comp right
there and as long as I have a good
ground bounce follow up FTC says no but
I think it's dope because you know a
ground bounce alone and every character
has a move that doesn't now that changes
the game that changes the meta like that
might not have been as useful or it
might have been maybe under par that's
gonna do yeah and I think it really just
opens up the combo system so much yeah a
lot of your old combo still work is just
now you have the ground bounce to look
I'll going to just more in depth later
but what we've also done in the quarter
of we adjusted the the juggle the juggle
limit so I think before a lot of times
people would find their combos like
hitting the juggle limit right before
they're about the end but we sort of
loosen those restrictions as well the
ground bounce so there's just you know
potential now the other thing I want to
talk about one of the major changes that
we have button dashing out oh oh my god
I actually saw a video of someone clean
caching I think was a nerd Josh someone
posted a video I was like whoa this is a
game changer hands down one of my
personal favorite things about like
Marvel and schoolgirls like the button
dashing that's huge for me because my
dexterity is trash and I hate
like hitting forward for your backpack
so and I've been here with you so yeah
two to two major changes we made to the
- is our 1 we have button dashes so if
you press light and medium you can dash
around but also the only light and
medium so oh yeah cuz throw is medium
heavy yeah that's correct so throws
medium heavy so - but with light medium
and if I time it right you know I can
just use the double double button input
to - wherever I want to go however we've
also added played dashing so if you
clink for those I don't know what
pointing means is yeah essentially uh
you're pressing yeah you're pressing the
button sort of really quickly in
succession so if this is actually let me
turn on the command history so see my
square and this is my triangle this is
me pressing at the same time this is me
plinking it right see how it gives me
two inputs so what I'm doing is I'm
pressing triangle and then square right
after and I'm holding it down so what it
does is that it gives me two inputs it
gives me the triangle and the double
button input to get a little technical
basically there's a very short window
frame I think two frames in which your
medium attacks can cancel into a dash so
what that lets you do is if you plank
m2l right and it's different for
different characters obviously lord zedd
he's not really a point - oh great
because we have to teleport E - which is
also super dope but we'll get to yeah
well but time force pink her for or for
punk that's really good there backlashes
was it slow you know it's sort of her
so what's really interesting about this
and I think different about our game is
that because you are plinking because
you're cancelling your stand medium into
a dash that means anything that you
cancel into span medium can also be
canceled into a dash so because I can go
LM or
L LM that means that can go out - and I
can go ll - and so that's really good
for pressure right so if I know that
push block me then I can just get right
in and it looks pretty straightforward
like you know - cancelling with buttons
that's very like I apologize for always
comparing this game I just can't help it
sometimes you guys let me know it I'm
not gonna lie though just the addition
of like button - e increased my interest
in playing this more like tenfold dude I
haven't even really gotten used to the
button dashing like I'm really curious
to see what like yeah so it's it's good
for it's good for setups it's good for
pressure and it's good for just movement
in general every character can blink -
some characters the timing is a little
bit different but the execution is the
same and of course the movement is
different depending on the character
alright something else I want to go over
is push block discernment so to be
honest the way that push block used to
work in the game is that if I'm blocking
something and I push blocks it creates
an invisible huge hitbox on the screen
which pushes out the enemy the problem
with that is that let's say I'm blocking
an assist and I push block it's gonna
push everything out because it doesn't
it doesn't discern between playing yeah
pointing assists or who I took the
attack from so now what push blocking
does and let me see if I can't if I
could demonstrate I can't
so yeah we need a second player for this
well basically what it means is that if
I'm blocking an assist and I push the
puck I'm only gonna push the assist if
I'm blocking a point character and push
I'm only gonna push the point not face
detection there yeah yeah and what it
really helps was for is the sort attack
so let's say you know we have like
Gold's are right and he has just crazy
sword attack or our dragon Zords drill
if I am blocking again and pushing
nothing's happening so now sort of like
those setups work the way that they're
supposed to where I'm getting pinned
down by the drill awhile if the
opponent's mixing me up right right so
it's it's a small change but it's it's
huge in that it's really changes you
know how push block works right right
you love the game and it forces you to
be more aware of confirming what your
push blocking instead of just knowing
you're blocking and then mindlessly
being I all pitch black get away now yes
wait because that was a big thing like
in Marvel 3 also the point was to be
mindful enough not to push block the
assist yeah because you're gonna be
bodied if you do that yeah absolutely
yeah I like that and the thing is in
Marvel 3 and it's it's it's even worse
than this came in that when you miss
push box Marvel 3 maybe you'll lift like
the heavy right like that it our game if
you miss a push fluff you might get a
special it's really something to be said
about you know people talk about
planning
yeah discipline people talk about hit
confirms all the time it's also blocking
for a very important you know I mean
yeah we've we've made major changes to
push blocking um something else I want
to go over and this was something that
we wanted to make sure that went in the
game so assists had been overhauled
greatly not so much in their function
but in their time so if I call Laura's
ed here we've increased the time in
which the assist is out on the screen by
30 frames by another second and so what
that does is it lets us do what it does
is that it gives you the way that tags
work in our game is that you call your
assistant you take over but now you have
a lot more time to take over so so she's
out I'm doing this what we've done is
we've really opened up the window for
you to mix up your opponent adding more
layers as a result not only as your
assistant longer and so they can be you
know punished they're more vulnerable
but we've also increased the damage that
assists take by 50% so you really know
yeah you really are so it's kind of like
this thing where we put more risk reward
on the syscalls so you have more time to
mix your opponent up you have more time
to take over but you also have to
protect your assist and you also want to
punish assist right yeah and to me a
more mindful decision to use you're
absolutely you can't just call them
brain-dead because really if your
character has if your sis character has
like 70% life and they get hit by a
super like they're dead yeah is it like
Marvel 3 like if you get happy birthday
does that damage scale to both them
getting hit or do they still take the
same amount of damage yeah and really
it's to me especially if you're playing
against like an opponent that's really
defensive you know I like that there's a
secondary goal of K well I can't hit you
let me hit your assistance day yeah I'm
saving my meter for that and I really
like the the dynamic of wanting to
protect my assists so intercept you
trying to punish my sister
and of course in battle for the grade
you can call both the same time that's a
next year huge gamble good luck right if
you guys make any adjustments to the
respawn of the assist it looks a little
faster but I could just be not
remembering very well how fast it was
last time I was just like nin this is
already I don't ready to check the notes
later another thing that we've fixed and
this is a big one it's something like
this it's something that if it works
correctly you don't notice if it doesn't
work correctly you notice and so what
we've done is and I this will happen to
me a lot when I'm playing and I would
watch other people playing it and just
what happen in law is basically we've
made our juggling easier in several
different ways one of the ways is that
to speak of it technically the physics
Collider so the quieter that makes me
push against my opponent
you know this quarter gets adjusted it
changes when they're in the air and
basically the adjustment is that if I'm
juggling you in the corner there'll be
times where I do that stand heavy and I
would be in the corner and kicking into
the corner and it would whiff and now
we've just made it to make sure that I
never happened so you're a juggler
always even if I'm running into the
corner
it's always gonna hit I mean when I do
did it when I find the correctly so
you're never gonna get behind your
opponents and with your button trying to
juggle when they're in a juggle state
another way that we made juggling easier
is that all Crouch ELLs juggle instead
of flip out so it allows you to catch
with I can always write so it gives me a
few more buttons to confirm with so so
the way it prevents you from like
getting underneath the character does
that also work you can see if you have
like crossed under setups or something
or those so yeah well so it depends so
in this trouble stay right here I can't
go under but this I think gold deals not
really a good character to demonstrate
this but in situations where you do a
flip out so this flip out right there
that you can still go underneath the
character no other characters work
something with gold it's a little bit
different but yeah you can still go
underneath one but that's all me if you
can't juggle if we do the flip out right
so I think players that are frustrated
that their combos drop we've really done
that for them
nice quality of life upgrades combos
another thing that we have added is this
juggle limit so if you see we have this
stunt I'm Angela Murray so this bar guy
says juggle in there you can't have it
all giving you all I can't have it all
all the information usually games sort
of keep bars like this like aunt mom
hidden or whatever but we straight up
for show
how much juggle limit you are in a
deacon combo right I mean this is how we
get optimal in training mode you can
really optimize your elbows to make sure
that you are hitting all the hits that
you want during the jump so in number
another quality of life change and what
else we erase so much I'm not yeah I
think I mentioned this before we've sort
of readjusted damage scaling and that's
different across every character also
the meter gain is a bit lower so it's
helped imagine and also yeah just juggle
scaling you can just get a little bit
more out of a juggle we just linked that
in the chat if you guys wanna check out
all the notes but to be honest I think
it's time to get down to business I want
to see some low dead he was DLC
character yeah shadows to everyone on
the team that you know made this guy and
all the other characters especially
season one possible Lords that is our
most polished character yet I feel he
just turned out awesome like his brains
are showing he's really really awesome
character I remember when I was young
yeah and they are the scariest you know
someone posted like a gif of like um you
know of Lord's face from one of the
older episodes and I was actually oh
yeah no he's very nuts feel like more
familiar yeah yeah and you guys did you
a really good job yeah he's my favorite
Power Rangers villain all the creative
yeah we kind of had to take some
creative liberties I hope everybody
enjoys it
so this is Lord Zedd he is sort of this
mid to long range character really
excels in the mid range not so much he's
best at mid range also good long range
not as good short range but his combo
potential is ridiculous so let me go
through some of the normals as there is
light light
like medium the fishermen swam and then
the reason why he's so good at mid-range
is this staff attacks right so who's
just an heavy to hits that they hit
sucks you in poorly attack is a lot of
his range and this is a sport heavy bar
the way to use this is that I call my
assist all right I do this back right
it's like an overhead and low at the
same time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
feel like you think of setups in your
mind and then you made the character did
a great job
I love his - yeah it's cool right so you
know obviously uses this for mix up so
I'll get into the mix of sort of special
moves later
this is Crouch light Crouch medium a bit
of range Crouch heavy it's an tyre of
course it's invincible - air attacks
jumpin L jumping medium double-double
staff attack and is jumping heavy is
overhead launcher right so I can just
come in - no rather yeah it's not super
in Styria all right it's pretty fast
yeah but the thing is his Crouch L is
not low so one of those characters that
you have to like look for the high back
of the low his Crouch medium is the only
low attacks yet okay yeah yes they kind
of have to like condition yourself to
that so his special moves neutral s sort
of summon some lasers right of course I
can I can mix up right
his backwards s is this sort of energy
move and it's really fast if you hit it
we want to eat in combos and if you hit
it it becomes invincible like anti-air
get off once it's powered up is when you
get the full benefit of it does more
damage and also I can comp off of it I
promise
[Music]
skinny combo into it so you can combo
into it you can combo out of it calmly
and then also his Ford specially has the
V putty right you guys are the buddies
right so funny story when we were first
before you know we started designing the
character and the 3d modelers were you
know modeling the character rigging it
shoutouts to Rimmel hopefully is in the
chat but he was like a dude I just made
you some putties in case you want to use
I think we didn't ask for it you know
and he's like we have the putty so he
made us the putties and sure enough we
had to incorporate it effectively the
putties are like a projectile right and
they kind of you know move on to the
screen anyone that's seen Power Rangers
know that the putty is just get beat up
all day long so you want to make sure
that the buddies got their looks in you
know what I mean so what's interesting
about Lord Zedd is that as you've seen
two of his moves are sort of delayed you
know right so what that does it really
lends well to anyone that has you know
experience and previous fighting games
that move similar to this is that when
you have moves that are delayed it
really extends your combo right you call
the move you do a couple hits and then
something that wouldn't normally combo
will let you comma because now the
putties gonna you know so as an example
let me see if I could do something
advanced here
knocking combo because of that because
of the pipe yeah advance combos will
have you doing stuff like that where you
call the putty after some sort of
balance and then continue the combo that
you wouldn't normally be able to do
without the putty right
oh yeah it's essentially projectile you
can stop in by it by Hill trip if you
take the damage that kind of thing
good question from the chest says can
you negative edge the putty summon I do
not think you can negative edge to put
them in with cherry now so I'm holding
special right now and the holding
forward and letting go yeah I get a veg
the putty from in however that's a good
question this was a change in one point
three some people forgot about this but
you can maybe you forgot but you
negative edge sword attacks now so I'm
holding light which when I let go is
when the board attack comes out and what
we the reason why we've done that is
that maybe I want to use the heavy sword
attack boat I want to start doing my
Carl with light medium so for those
super advanced players that have you
know seven fingers on one hand what you
can do is that you can hold light right
and if I want to combo the sword attack
light from heavy then I press heavy and
let go it's when you let go so if I do
and so okay whoever's you know making
combo videos out there put that feature
just for you yes yeah we want to give
players advanced players more control
over a resort a tactical anyway so back
to lure Zed air special you're looking
move home breaker move and what's cool
about this thing crossa
yeah what's cool about this music it's
really good for us this takeover right
so if I call suddenly I have a home
breaker and this really speaks to and I
you know hate to toot our own horn here
it's really that they assist takeover
system it really opens up you know we
have regular assist but it's a matter of
pick your own assist with the assist a
proper system right right
Trey's assist he normally does rush but
if I want to do the golden crush as an
assist
then I basically call Z&S yeah that's
really you know Mon to make sure we have
a new system anyway and then of course
Lord that's super
and notice the putty comes from the back
right so the way that this pudding works
the initial putty works is that this
move at the hip grabs so you cannot
block it and you can also combo it so it
works as a throw but you cannot hit it
from a juggle you cannot ocg with it so
pretty much you can always jump out of
it if you see it coming but all it takes
is like if I have full if I'm full
screen and the other character is doing
anything that's not like looking for it
I can just do that very powerful so
example of some of lords that's combos
you wear warm learn how to use the mmm
there's composition itself Oh something
else I should mention so we have the
tech now to limit how many hit reactions
you can do in one combo so for example
we talked about the ground bounces right
however you only get one ground balance
in a combo so if I try to do that same
combo again
it's splats hmm and which is still
pretty good yeah and it's still simple
for ball bounces too so in the case of
Lords edge this mm causes the ground
bounce but if I do it again it will
cause it's getting knocked out so and
play Lord Zedd you got to learn how to
compost examples of Lords that compost
and then set them up with a putty -
forward corner yeah
practicing these combos just for you
guys
exclusive nods and combos
well that's game yet you got 20/20 well
if you guys didn't see the hype from
this path Evo we did have some awesome
battle for the grid shenanigans
happening at Evo thanks to cross-counter
and you guys are at the eSports arena
and I also have to show you amazing
pictures are you showing us what are you
sure I show you guys right now this is a
quick dress though like oh my gosh I
wanted to focus it was fantastic clog
our dress up as a ranger and went and
played against people I think I have one
with most of the suit on here this was
right before you went to go like body of
this guy actually I think you lost yeah
shoutouts to skillz that killz and smoke
max these guys made it were the first
and second place at the bar fights
exhibition so for those that don't know
Friday we ran a tournament at the cross
counter booth Friday and Saturday and
the winners of that play that bar fight
that evil
shut up so everyone that came by the
booth that played in the tournament
yeah it was awesome shout out to
everyone then we showed the Lord Taylor
treadeth and the bar fights and everyone
went nuts yeah it was sick man yeah
shout to everyone that supported us an
Evo battle for the grid and everyone
that the cops on the team on the n way
team and everyone you know the guys from
Fresno Jared everyone that helped Sierra
everyone that made it made it possible
yeah
all right I think it's time for some
online matches work I think we've just
about rushed down the chat with all the
info we can and yeah let's get some
matches going we did except a bunch of
friend requests already yep but we'll
probably take a quick look and see if
any new ones came in yep then we're
gonna send the invites out to you guys
and we're gonna be running some three
out of aisles if you are on ps4 right
now first you got to add Sam on PSN so
Persia EXO yes all one word yep and then
when you are in we can direct match with
your anyway play ID and it is Persia EXO
pound aka hash tag hash tag if you're if
you're younger
hash tag twenties thirties seven twenty
eight wait thirty seven twenty twenty
eight thirty seven yeah Persia hash tag
twenty eight thirty cents well let me
invite some people right now version EXO
hash tag yeah we're just gonna check for
some some new friends friend of quests
new friends new friends very nice and
then we're gonna try to play as many
games with you guys for the next hour so
but yeah and sorry we didn't get to do
too much interaction in the first half
hour only because we're gonna make sure
we get all those details with the patch
notes and everything but now that we're
going into some matches what's up
everyone
nice to see some returning faces and
everyone that's excited for some battle
for the grid now Frank G skillz that
killz mystical Nisha's back hey shouts
the skillz that killz got first place I
Evo battle for the grid right we go they
battle for the grid Evo champ in the
chat you think I would be a century
changes echoes yeah let us know what do
you think about this update alright so
we're gonna be sending out some invites
okay Sahab I'd choose the first match
and then you guys can call the matches
after that okay cool
sounds good alright let's see who we got
here
hey extra the extra you want to play
some matches I'm gonna send you an
invite you in the chat hey fun fact
these guys had a little practice match
before the stream and let's just see
clock want some vengeance alright
actually let's do it
give me your best shot if you got a
fireplace three out of five sets let's
do it yeah 3 out of 5 burning skull asks
which fighting games were you most
inspired by and were any of them by
chance arcs of skins hey so I'm gonna at
least on my side me personally that the
games that inspired me when we were
doing design for this game one while we
were doing design for this game
definitely Marvel - Marvel 3 Marvel
Infinite and BB tag really is a BB tag
right before I started working on this
project and they had so many good
mechanics right holding forward to run
instead of having a - B they sort of
have a version of the assist takeover
it's more of like a system that you know
uses me here and all this stuff so we've
sort of like loosen that up in our game
but and I also was inspired a bit by
some CVS - you know I just moved to
NorCal for the job and we also putting a
lot of CVS to know that first month so
yeah I took inspiration from all the
Marvel games CVS to be be tagged yeah
nice I mean that's probably one of my
favorite things about this game is the
fact that you and shady worked on it you
guys are Marvel players I'm like I
already know those games gonna be cheap
that's how we like there's some
masochist
alright actually at first the three
let's do it alright level zero versus
level 3 84 like yeah that's what the
power that I don't know about the
scaffolding the power levels here I'm
just a small fish in the pond level zero
mirth account alright a [ __ ] Lord
Zedd action
said wake up helm breaker these are the
marble players I'd know that was a
character I was using when I first
started playing this dude she's
beautiful no bonus no spy yes
oh the ground bounce uh someone's been
practicing the last two days I blocked
it my goodness in theory we want to show
off that words that is good here we go
here we go we got some space some real
estate
Oh oh man extras getting real extra on
me right now
stay warm done oh those nice oh he
definitely gave more character who named
the big control taking this game is 20
bucks it's available now on switch and
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one so go ahead
and snag that all of the patch updates
have been free and there are also some
new Diaz VLC characters for purchase so
definitely check it out because this
game has a ball it was good already and
now it's even better let's go built with
the fighting game player in mind don't
throw me
Clockwerk making my account live real
good you wanna cross off cartwheel cross
our domain weather the storm that is
true skillz that killz there is also a
full story mode and this patch also
introduced an extended story mode and
tutorial ya know it just keeps getting
better that's right ninja and if you've
seen our previous streams oh snap ex
residence at Weston oh yeah these are
previous battle for the grid streams
that we've had here with clockwork
you'll also know that a lot of the voice
actors in this game are actually the
voice actors of these rangers they've
paid like such amazing homage to the
show itself yeah Green Ranger Red Ranger
Zordon yeah we got a lot of oh jeez
doing the voices so if you are Power
Rangers fan this is a game for you if
you're a Power Rangers fan you never
played a fighting game this is twice the
game for you because I would say it's
not only friendly to new fighting game
players but also in-depth enough for
veteran fighting game players also he's
such a villain he gets all this
enjoyment out of just throwing you
around oh that was dangerous now I'm
like don't get your ass biscuit
[Music]
gonna catch this work lecture let's talk
about this let's talk about this that
was nice he respect what he knew he knew
this coming blacks and then he punished
nice I like that take over combo with
the time for us picking at the edge run
it back
they've all said being in the fgc and a
Power Rangers fan maybe pick this up
alright it's like double whammy I just
read it up where do they go
they've oh they don't hey yeah shower
Tuesday though thank you so much for
supporting the game yeah thanks so much
again it's really the support that makes
all this possible yeah shouts everyone
that creates content tweets about us
yeah which reminds me if you guys even
want to join the battle for the grid
discord there's a lot of awesome
community members there who heavily
sparked the theme
there's just so much information there
too if you're just learning it or
picking it up or anything like that so
go ahead and join that disk or it gets
another community yes that'll help you
some of us from the end weight team are
off on the report as well yeah I mean
coming from me marvel three player a
game with dev support is very very a
nice and the fact that these people have
been in our community for many many
years goes to show that there's a lot of
care and effort put behind this game and
a lot of mindfulness puts behind this
game for quality of life fighting game
you know elements dirty oh I feel like
often easy to play but hard to master is
just the motto of fighting games in
general it's really the first step is
just taking a fund right right yeah
exactly
it's not as hard as you think in theory
is easier right but the goal
take out their life bar throw some
punches and kicks in some plasma but to
master at all yeah that's difficult part
but it's so rewarding that's why I like
fighting is when you do land that combo
or you things start to click nothing's
more rewarding
oh man
yo clock what's up what's up you need to
show your lord zedd superiority right
now okay you're rid of pink switches
don't come back on that's all I gonna
say calmly - okay staying alive don't
get come back oh nice blacks like we're
traveling - well nice finish the job
it's still one
we're doing three out of five y'all Oh
version 1.4 ladies and gentlemen no
choruses that assists given one point
four smite said don't call your sis
using the 1.0 everyone outside is like
what happened in this in the stream room
right now is everyone still alive if
it's to be one just play it out right
you know that was a perfect example of
what not to do in that situation
thanks Clark demonstrating new changes
here examples right now I loved
everything about that actually
so two one now the extra one more game
yeah that was one heck of a comeback and
then just said happy birthday clock in
Dida oh man yeah time course she's
looking freaky deaky both box jumps are
over that mu wow that catches both of
them you cheese mofos that hurt
[Music]
saw what happened last time any acidity
oh my god
triples Lord combo think cou he called
the dev team real quick I was like hey I
need you to make this drop I can't let
this comeback happen oh man yes converse
this really is a Power Rangers fighting
game and it is top tier high quality
content okay 20 bucks 20 bucks 20 bucks
definitely not bad 20 bucks in that 20
bucks guys also gets you three free DLC
character and then there's another three
that you could buy yeah
that's six possible characters you can
get the story motors all three story
mode extended tutorial for those of you
who are really on the fence oh the staff
Oh
shady wrong wrong person oh yeah he
tried to hit you with the truth jazz oh
okay
nice all that is an amazing air-to-air
button holy smokes
now we know this extra so many so many
cheeky said okay oh the staff that was a
lot of scrambled eggs there in the
corner whoo
that was sick oh thank you shady let's
go it's super effective all right
incoming nerve block block block block
we got a block yes now you don't even
try it don't even try it
[Applause]
all right I feel like the threat is gone
here I feel like we might be okay oh oh
you almost converted oh okay yeah you're
not dead oh and then the throw reset
plastics okay
shady wrong person again gonna have to
have some words after this street
oh hey nice game GG's clock date 232 we
going out yes very close yeah you're
tight you're no no I'll see your
characters are really good yeah time
first pink you know some TFP nice
matches makes me want to play her for
sure for sure yeah let's get the next
who well you know I've been seeing Evan
in the chat being nice and patient so
let's in heaven and invite event let's
go even oh yeah yeah so those that don't
know so we had a tournament on Friday
and we had a tournament on Saturday and
the two winners of one at bar fights on
Saturday that the competition was very
ferocious even here got second place has
a really good who Donna and even show us
new Donna oh yeah I love you Donna she's
cool
alright actually are you in the chat
maybe he's away from this oh yeah maybe
actually he wasn't here a second ago
yeah well we can get back to my feet
okay alright yeah rip the last thing he
said was that's what you get welcome
back to yeah welcome back to yeah all
right Zuko you in the chat Oh a StuCo
calling you out hey show us the souk oh
man he's always about wait Gavin week I
know he was a talking to us on Twitter
he's there wakey boy I'm assuming that's
him hey wiki boy you want to play let's
play Briscoe wakey boy boy direct
challenge it's like so personal we'll
play you next yeah yeah we got to yeah
and if week doesn't doesn't accept and
bye
we're here all day for the next 45
minutes you got this okay so we hopped
up so skillz that killz will invite you
or excuse me will accept your friend
invite after this we definitely have a
play the Evo champion yeah
all right well wakey boy stupid and
evens back okay snooze you lose music
after he said I don't mind waiting
it's very polite to you but let's play
it out oh yeah that was towards you my
bad I was mashing I'm sorry I hope they
didn't mess up our direct challenge yeah
sorry I was mashing try it again
oh we played last time right Zuko yeah
and then after this we'll also head back
to the friend request box and see who
else we can accept oh yes it was because
I was mashing I probably sent you two at
the same time so hey Stu ko why don't
you invite me I think I messed it up
when I was mashing yeah shoutouts to
everyone that's a yeah in the in the
chat everyone back at the office that's
watching oh yeah we're gonna go back
skillz that killz and man max we're
gonna invite you guys or we're going to
accept the friend request indeed indeed
and then we'll send out possibly those
invites again but yeah you guys update
is pretty fresh
I like this like the direction that this
game is going I mean I'm not sure if you
guys can talk about it but like is this
it was is this the goal avoiding a minor
is there like more improvements you guys
are worth tweaking on here and there's
constantly things to improve the grind
never stops so we're you know as long as
we're working a sign of a good games
long as working on the game and it's
we're committed to improving the game as
much as we can for us
as we can and it really it's the support
from you know all the players the
community content creators such as
yourself and influencers really getting
us on the on the map yeah hey stoop go
you back yeah invite me or I can invite
you oh nice goob setting up a queue for
us here in queue skills egg Hill's aka
snoop oh wait and then StuCo yeah nice
thanks goob MVP
it's alright Gavin oh I'll still send
one to you okay so skillz that killz
invite us on on anyway place so I can
see you rock ooh Yuki says I'm just
waiting to get it on switch yep sorry
are you trashed that mash I'm gonna
invite you
I think it's trashed that mash is that
him are you just taking a jab at his
character at his fight style day
[Music]
the shade he said he sent us one maybe
did you see any invites in our
notifications Oh actually StuCo now I
see you oh there yeah I'm gonna invite
you oh wait you were right that was
skillset kills oh I know we're bouncing
all over the place here it's fine tried
to invite you it didn't pop up I also
have notifications off so that's why I'm
saying maybe the invite is going
straight through the PS PS in instead of
enjoy comparison face yeah we're gonna
make sure everything is good to go but
yeah yeah so they are showing you Eve it
was awesome do you just see people come
by the booth and the game and casuals
are a tournament it's it's it's nuts man
and it's nice to see people like you
know you you make a character and then
they're supposed to play a certain way
or have certain combos and then you see
people come up with like a completely
different stuff that ya expect it's wild
man like all the combos that skillz that
killz was hitting me with at the redbull
at that bar fights after-party I didn't
expect a lot of that stuff that's
probably one of the funnest things right
seeing what comes of these characters
that you made and then ripping everyone
else's tech um I mean Twitter is an
amazing place to go watch some of these
like combos and stuff follow those
hashtags you know all that good stuff
alright let's start fresh hey smoke max
are you in the chat let's start fresh
since again wait our one real quick oh
yeah I think maybe it's in the little of
notifications box instead of I mean you
just restarted it so it might have
refreshed but hey hey hey smoke Mac so
I'm gonna try to invite you let's start
let's start fresh all right
smoke max hey what's up Bob Jones
welcome back has gone yeah well sure I
think we all the invites that we're
getting and all the invites that I was
sending out I think it's making it go
wonky oh hey yes oh snap so we have some
tournaments coming up we have a
tournament tomorrow actual tomorrow oh
dang
so it's tomorrow and that is at the San
Francisco the mall yeah I'm not from
around this area I forget what that you
know the name of the mall is I will have
that information on the social media but
yeah it's it's it's gonna be it's a free
to enter tournament I believe and we
have you know prizes and plenty of
battle for the grid setups and all the
times out and we also have I wanna check
the notifications on PSN yeah okay
because I'm pretty sure it's like maybe
you're getting yes yeah yeah so I'm
getting the invitations on PSA okay so
we are getting your invitations it's
just going through PSN and not through
anyways so we didn't see them so now
we're gonna accept some of these
challenge accepted yeah sorry I didn't
realize that was going through hopefully
this one's not yeah hopefully your
invites are okay there we go
Noli anyway so yeah we have a free
tournament tomorrow
in San Francisco downtown at the mall
we'll have the information as far as
hmm but it's at the microscope that the
Microsoft Store oh cool tomorrow
oh wait that's not tomorrow that's like
next week yeah oh excuse me
I thought of tomorrow oh my bad today's
the 15th
it's all your fault
extra yeah we'll have that we'll have
that information ready for you guys as
soon as we have it but it was a free
tournament you know I'll be there just
to check out likely you know what's
going on and talk to people are there
prizes there are definitely prizes not
only from the Microsoft Store as well
extra you all you check it out yeah
check it out man that's awesome so it's
at a mall downtown Sanford was filmed
San Francisco Center Microsoft Store so
smoke max got second place at bar fights
evil so he won the Friday Turner man
yeah more cat but I see who Donna
just a Goldar
[Music]
nice the pressure yeah we slowed down
like this fast-paced fast-paced anywhere
Aaron was like wait hold it oh my goal
I'm so good at first when I was like in
training mode and I was doing like the
s4 he just summons the Z I was like man
I wonder how effective that's gonna be
like on his own apparently very
effective great so smoke max got second
out bar vibe I got first on Friday
that's it at the other tournament Evans
like he deserves the respect of the
acknowledgment of his first placing
first place placing so you're right he
was number one on that day the toes
yeah Bob Jones so said is wrecking
people no absurd that is just one of my
favorite things about like a villain if
he's not truly truly just enjoying the
pain he's inflicting on people is he
really a real villain
I don't know smoke max pick it up buddy
show me that bar fights tell me that bar
flash form
all right smoke max you got a show clock
what you would have done to him how do
you won and you had to face off against
him oh snap you cheat games in the chat
yeah we're still listen we we're still
on for a little bit longer yep over like
half an hour we have left so walking
time your majesty hop on in there
hey Yugi can you confirm this is the
correct ESquared links we're trying to
help some people through the cause
extra said that was a warm-up match ok
warm-up match me too ok now it's your
time to impress don't let us down for a
reset but I don't know this but now we
have you lords dead Oh Donna wholesome
after listening to Lord Zedd just laugh
at everyone's pain didn't like what you
had to say about his performance last
game turning up the heat
oh we jump in
your meetings aren't tight that's what
he says awesome correctly for the winner
Oh give me that who Donna where is she
where is she you survived
Wow first the X but Lord said is
superior Bing eg Jane said I just got a
haircut gonna grab a sandwich and then
I'm downs ablaze
thank you for letting us know oh he's no
longer EG games he's gucci games fresh
cut oh that hurts the trade escalating
things one-to-one Evan says crotch have
you from Zedd is OD StuCo I can't help
it it's it's the game the game brings
out but the - me true Lord Zedd bad
always cheering for the like my favorite
like whine of Magneto's and Marvel is
when he does like gravity squeeze he
just laughs at you huh it's like same
energy yeah
all right who did the voice for Lord
said again give this man a raise
superior laughing oh dang Oh Donna yeah
and a few matches maybe after this one
we'll head back and accept or maybe in
the next two we do have a couple people
in the queue right now but we'll
definitely look back and accept more
requests soon so stay tuned we are
running three out of five s right now
but our queue is getting kind of long we
might we might bump it down to some few
out of threes in a Cell voice actors
original vo for gold are two by the way
you did that guy I love that half of his
lines are just like grunts and murmurs
red
I've had a couple of people talk about
how they went Rita in this game I would
be down with that - just cuz she's
probably look like most memorable
villain for me personally I'd she's
definitely one of the first ones I think
oh god those shows were so old I
remember watching them I don't remember
them too in-depth but shows back then
we're crazy cuz they had less CGI but
more hand stuff see a pattern here every
time there's an ax on IX battle clocks
characters are just superior alright two
one smoke max I'm spray yes so smoke max
was hey smoke were you using the same
team at bar fights at Evo I coulda sworn
you were using century I don't know I
like him the gold art play man nice
combos does the ground series into the
shoulder charge cops we open to the
anti-air throws is pretty cool
I feel like I'd be so greedy to hit
assists with this recent patch yeah
absolutely
like don't even call that assist without
backing them go oh that was that was
fair nice
that any action
ooh check out ha ha and he spent the bar
that's ok is like oops
Oh rain drip
Foucault said I just need one game and
I'm happy the confidence from behind
yeah I think that's your favorite setup
you get extra - eel in the hood oh yeah
I like I really like that let's just
take over mixed up so did my favorite
mix ups in the game I need to master
like having both assists out at once and
then taking over between 1 & 2 that drop
[Applause]
feels bad miss minks she's also left oh
you have to make him pay max you have to
make him pay with his life that - what
is that 31 that's 300 a nice game's
smoke max GG's let's get the next victim
in here I'm just embracing my interval
and today thanks to Lord Zedd
yeah nice game small packs
we should play against wait where's our
cues who had a queue up here you guys
got these spam scrolling up oh yeah so
skillz that killz is next hey skillz
that killz invite me and if it doesn't
show up by anyway play maybe it'll show
up on PSN we don't have our
notifications on so yes
indeed indeed yeah so skillz that killz
let us know when you are also I mean I
don't know if it's not showing up for
you guys but if we send you an invite
you should check your PSN notifications
instead of your anyway as well oh yeah
invite me let us know when you've
invited okay yeah
so far so good though yeah I mean yeah
we're one for two for two two old
Bacchus yeah but I mean growing up
against the Evo champion right now Oh
champ versus dev the run back challenge
accepted challenge group says the queue
is I completely forgot it's okay I
scrolled up we found it
we're in there no see oh you know it's
know about skillz that killz he plays
Cenozoic blue hey oh yeah really curious
to see what you think about yes oh yeah
I know you were a blue player yeah yeah
his combos are yeah his combos are way
opened up because of the ground bounce
let me try some different actually I
feel that kills I'm gonna play a
business team at least my Zed business
team and if it doesn't work I'm gonna
play some Ranger Slayer after
cool cool yes after this we'll play a
set with StuCo we'll play a set with
wake and then we'll go back and accept
new friend requests so stick around
sorry it's taking some time we just want
to make sure we get some matches in with
everybody yeah yeah person but uh you
know handing out these ELLs takes time
and effort it's a little bit effort I
suppose I feel like I'll never get over
that I almost want to play this with no
sound effects and just voice I'll be so
good oh my god
effective in every game he did he did
skillz that killz I was talking you over
don't make me look stupid
I mean you talking about your skills
that killed sorry that was low blood
work not he's alive that was hype though
but he how do you all do dashes like
that ask mkay 40 in the chat well we got
some wavedashing and pulling dashing
fresh off the presses
courtesy of patch version 1.4 definitely
one of my favorite additions to this
game and you know alongside the ground
bounce of course you just saw some
pretty sick stuff I feel like we
shouldn't release like a tutorial video
on some of the new stuff right - it
definitely totally would be worth it
yeah but m'kay 40 just answer your
question really quick we're pressing M
and L like one after that is you doing
like ml ml ml ml mm-hm and once you get
the timing down for it you'll you'll be
able to do it forward or backwards with
that same time
there are certain windows in the - where
you're allowed to cancel it so once
you're mindful of like where those
windows lie it becomes like pretty
intuitive yeah they'll become second
nature once we're in like the timing
doesn't matter of getting a feel for it
right guys finish these combos yeah if
you played Marvel 3 you'll know all
about playing dashing wavedashing and I
I guess what is that stop bugging out my
game breaking the game never ends
where's that juggle limit now oh okay oh
oh my gosh now by balloon give me the
goods blue no oh he tried to make me up
Oh oh my god I was like three signs oh
[Music]
do it oh my god you look at my ex-wife
oh this got really close really fast
thanks to that happy birthday we're good
for good for good for good for good re
though are we
okay okay
oh the throw that bullet those oh you
don't want it you don't want those of
you this is what you're telling me right
now we're good we're good
oh that deep in every single overhead
that defense it's not a block of all
proof I got it on footage oh I wasn't
recording just kidding I know that was
good um - oh I think it's - OH
Sheils that kills oh he said he blocked
the overhead I'm cook he blocked it
multiple I think what it is so he
actually beat me a TiVo and you know
he's really good player by thing no one
today is ready for a lord says right
lord zedd has stepped in to the ring
he's changed the game letter
if if clock had Lord Zedd at Evo this is
what the result would have been oh nice
combo oh my god ooh we are chilling
right there oh my god a dreamer I had
never seen that magnet oh pretty Wow
lordy Lordy did we have some time to
contemplate our life during that summer
or what running about oh you're
definitely dead this time here holy drop
it thanks JD where was this magnet the
last two matches Sam bagging he wanted
more screen time I see you SD gay milk
in those the screen time here Oh
if you have your assists out and your
point character gets hit he's still tied
no right you sure you want to risk
losing your damage right now I'll know
blue is pretty scary too
the blender I wanted to see his hand on
his I can't stick when he tried to block
all that overhang okay okay we're live
we're living oh yeah that hurt
Oh Oh
he wants it so bad oh look the bullet is
back ouch oh my gosh oh really
we live in the power of evil evil and
putties oh that was slick from
off-screen to kill ooh
hey the drill for the assist free Oh
over the Evo champ nice games dude nice
games Gigi's got Lord Zedd man I
practice combos last night about half of
them
yeah nice games dude I really liked that
century play man I can movement I might
play Cenozoic blue next match up next is
StuCo hey Zuko send me an invite let me
know when you sends it to me
Stu Kazuko you're next buddy
yeah now is your chance for the run back
ya know that combo was super hype what
kind of sandwich should get who's she oh
yeah weird let me judge you on your type
of sandwich you ordered yeah be careful
about your answer you say Bologna or
insta band
oh yeah SP is not ready for that said oh
yeah alright so let's accept this invite
real quick up next after this Q is awake
if you're still in here and then we're
gonna accept some friend requests and
get some more invites out we are getting
down towards our last like 10 minutes or
so so we'll still try to get to as many
people as possible yeah sooo cool I
think our our stuff just doesn't like
each other yeah so now we're sending you
once to go cuz yours didn't work on Aarn
so check your notifications your psn
ones there you go there we go we're in
there I'm just kidding what kind of
sandwich I got was a hamburger says the
dec oh dude you got a BL tizzle Oh show
me Laura said okay you can play large
that off with someone else
I like gold and I'm gonna go Rangers
play actually put right maybe we should
bump these down to two out of three
should be because we still have wake and
then another person Ronnie really wants
to play okay okay a Stuka will do quite
a few for this match I mean you did say
be happy with just one so I'm giving you
the courtesy of it to masazuka level -
OH - let me see what that zeg can do I
don't think we played against anyone
that you said Yeah right
show me yeah StuCo is on twitter you
could just search him and he post is
been posting all kinds of cool stuff
with Zed and other characters yeah all
right
Twitter tech warriors guys are the best
oh oh you're about all I'll update I'll
turn you into a Twitter combo video real
quick
it's definitely Maura
- happy with the character than my god
oh my goodness nobody not even the devs
are ready for Lord Zedd oh my gosh
no incoming being black is mind-boggled
right now my berry yeah I'm like you're
trying to get your life together she
does power wash your feet man oh please
just throwing it out there whoo all
right yeah sometimes we get things
we learn to take those tale combo no
[Laughter]
we're gonna get some lord zedd mirrors
here actually I think I'm gonna go with
I need to counter I'm gonna do Oh Stu
cousin I had to let you look good for a
second Wow
it was the carrot on the string and he
just yanked it away you know let me run
that team back yeah you got him he's got
him just change the order okay okay you
you you got him right in the pride right
in the ego I like it SDK he inspired me
to play blue this match song I hear yes
Oh Lord Zedd
that is Lord that is correct dude you
baby hit him with all you've got old
snack oh she's terrifying
oh the oppression does the putty get
nullified by other projectiles on ice
[Music]
oh snap oh man don't do it but now the
Lord is out it's kind of survived
Oh horrible Oh Oh No big mistake joking
don't let Lord Zedd intimidate you all
right this is going to come down
straight up one-on-one
that yours or it lasted way longer than
I thought realize that come back he
basically gambled the two characters are
called 1 1 1 1 1 1 what happens Duke oh
I've only talking all that hot smack in
the chain
no that's looking nice to go you do the
advanced combos I haven't learned those
yet but yeah I've completed one combos
render Slayer we're gonna go for what
one more this match hopefully maybe that
tail saved you
Oh juicy Oh Oh the snowball effect right
now all the moment all Oh give me that
Zed is he still in give me that oh my
god are you still in oh you left at the
time oh you got hit it went away okay
okay it's air fare oh oh oh oh
unfortunate oh my god oh my Oh like I'm
done giving you opportunities oh oh
mercy on me alright so you've come back
so I forgot all my blue combos and I'll
practice good job Duke Oh takes it to
one I'm trying to be on your thigh clock
but you're leaving me little choice
up next is wave hey soul or weak sorry
wait girl we keep ooh yeah we can fight
me and then let me know what and then
while we're waiting for that invite
we're also going to accept some more
friend requests
honestly we only really have time for
this next match and maybe one more after
that okay okay so yeah we're good it's
been very fun wake you in the chat yes
he's in here I see him StuCo said I
redeemed SDK day just really really
going for it just putting the knife in
throw some salt in the wounds well I
think he's in the chat oh he always
sending okay sorry
noise noise sorry I ever doubted you all
good just waiting for this invite to
come through honestly this might have to
be the last one actually okay depending
on how long it takes for this invite
something so yeah we'll definitely have
more opportunities to play some more
matches on future streams yeah it's a
there's plenty of beatdowns to go around
Oh actually the man Stalin he's already
on our friends list I think okay so okay
I got the invitation
all right cool will play weak and then
we'll play Stalin to two out of three
shouldn't take too too long so what's up
shredder Bob Turner Bob said something
earlier about a community and fgc for
this game which there definitely is one
here is a link to the discord if you're
interested in joining it and yeah uh
yeah so oh by the way guys in way and
the people who make this beautiful game
they stream also so if you enjoyed this
then definitely follow them on twitter
at battle for the number four battle for
the grid and stay tuned to when they go
live and they also play matches with
viewers so if we couldn't
you today they play on their stream as
well and you can play with clock and
also shady K over there so yeah please
follow us on all the social you'll get
the up-to-date news on new updates right
new content like content from the
community that we blast out yeah please
follow us alright two out of three to
Twitter for you right yes to every three
back to action the launch head are you
back on bed now do you think oh yeah oh
geez autocorrect
you've got some big shoes to fill clock
after watching Stu cozy you guys have
any plans for Gamescom or any other
conventions for that matter you guys
right now what you guys know nice
awesome we try to make it so like the
Power Rangers ponds and whatnot yeah
well we'll have a schedule yeah great
question
shout out to Jason Biggs for that one
yeah the game is getting good content
right now especially from the community
on Twitter there's a ton of awesome tech
and combo videos and discoveries and all
that good stuff and then in general a
huge patch up day all around a bunch of
awesome additions to the game to the
combat and the fighting style a lot of
free content yes all free of 1.4 is free
but it also does introduce some paid DLC
including Lord Zedd but you know you get
Story 3 free characters are downloadable
Cenozoic blue dragon armor Trini and
Donna from mystic force mm-hmm and yeah
also paid dlc season one cast you can
see Time Force pink on wakey boys side
also Lord Zedd and gold Zeo and
obviously a lot of future plans and
support still on the way
like a little bit over wheat they're
gonna have the local tournament here in
San Francisco as a Microsoft Store so
more info is coming for that it's a free
to enter tournament and now it's just a
perfect time to get into the game after
any big huge patch like this you
shouldn't feel intimidate you shouldn't
feel like you're too far behind already
because it's practically fresh for
everyone with these changes and yeah
it's great the game itself is only 20
bucks 20 bucks that's pretty good
there's not a lot of quality things you
could buy for 20 bucks anywhere that's
like half a dinner in San Francisco
oh well that's right and for any you
know NorCal locals we do have Wednesday
night fights at the each price Arena in
Oakland and there are also tournaments
there for this game so definitely a
great other avenues and opportunities
and places and venues to get involved I
don't think they like those games
underrated we're here for ah
we are an invincible respect us did what
was the name of their like leader he is
just the floating holographic head for
Doc yeah we need him in the game yeah be
like MODOK yeah nice games wakey so much
for playing yeah you geez wakey let's
get sahlan in here one yeah exactly
great I mean sorry that it was too oh
but that helped us and getting in
another match here nice games
hey stalling you so much yeah Ronnie
he's still here Ronnie cream we're
sending a new one next I think he's
already on our in wait please the mad
style in there would go because I let
him play no we got it we got a show we
got to show the full effect so that when
you know you pick up this game and play
and get good you know you should be
doing to people oh sorry I think I was
mashing oops I might have messed it up
so wrong one row on ya sorry Ronnie you
might get a you might get two invites
from me
hey let me know if you get it
and if this doesn't work you can just
invite me yeah so this is gonna be the
last match of the day on the stream here
but like we mentioned before the folks
over at in way they stream and play
matches with viewers all the time so
feel free to follow them if you want to
get more matches if you're a said you
couldn't play with us today it's totally
fine there's more opportunities on the
way and hey yeah follow that discord
let's just go ahead and link that again
since we're getting towards the close of
the show also if you want all those
juicy 1.4 patch notes that is also at
this link as well and then yeah gotta
follow these guys on top all the social
goodness that is that battle number for
the grid I'll go ahead and include that
in there also
so yeah just go ahead and support
there's so much great like I don't know
content and new things on the way but
one of my most favorite things about
this game is that we got some better and
fighting game players straight up
representing and making good games for
us so we live in with some udana let's
go
Oh ripp choices above the neutral jump
nice I'm no longer impressed with this
large set clock you brought this on
yourself
I do love it like has elements of
everything I enjoy we get the Thanos
snap we get like the the doctor dude
chilling in the chair we get all the
people like all the Felicia
you know exactly it's like a little bit
of everything is green
[Music]
come back time oh my god oh man so
useful that ground bounce now it's
really good anytime you get an area like
straight hit just always press the heavy
right you get your ground balanced and
then just continue to come home really
we're really happy with the way the
ground Boston goes yeah no it's awesome
we've done wonders for the combo system
in my opinion
indeed especially those like blue combos
we were seeing earlier yeah those are
hype yeah and those combos were you know
possible because of the ground oh yeah
really help you out a lot it's pretty
cool how fighting games like one small
change can change the entire game ask
Twitter Sodor knows all right Clark I
believe in you aw man commentators curse
within the millisecond like within the
same breath
[Music]
Oh blocks up on the tree yeah that his
medium like pushes him forward to its
deceivingly like effective hey kyon
shudder bomb he says I like what I see I
think I'm gonna grab this well we're
happy to help you in your decision and
it's worth a nice putties I like the
thumbs down here so it's like character
Ronny good stuff and good stuff to
everybody who joined us today like it
was really fun thank you clock for
coming through also thank you to Rose
helping us with all the fine details but
yeah she she's helping us make sure we
get all the correct information to you
guys which is also super helpful with a
huge update like this and all the stuff
on the horizon for battle for the grid
on the way is worth picking this game up
for ya so again the games $20 available
in 10 dos which PlayStation 4 Xbox one
the new version just came out version
1.4 it's a free update has story mode
act 3 there's also three new characters
season 1 characters including Lord Zedd
time force pink and zeal gold also the
three free character Cenozoic blue
dragon armor Trini and Donna from mystic
force and if you want to get any more
information about the game or the patch
notes go to battle for the good comm
follow us on social etcetera etcetera
thank you so much for the support
exactly and tomorrow is going to be
community Fridays so if you guys want to
play some MK 11 and catch some night
wolf action with a bin and John Luke
make sure you tune on in
and actually later on this afternoon
Tony and I will be playing man of Madan
which is like a horror game co-op so I'm
ready to get scared and be a big ol
chicken it's gonna be great so tune in
later this afternoon as well you guys
are awesome and we'll see you guys next
time